[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry more
specifically we're going to be
addressing
one simple question does hogwarts cost
money hogwarts was founded in the 10th
century
when four witches and wizards got
together and decided that they had
in the sorting hats own words their
selves same yearning to make the world's
best
magic school and create the world's best
magic school they did
teaching magic to generations and
generations
of magical families for centuries the
children of the magical world have been
receiving their hogwarts acceptance
letters
the moment they come of age they can
expect a letter their door
and the letter is symbolic in that it
represents a new chapter in their lives
in one moment they're struck with the
realization that they're going to be
leaving their homes and families behind
in pursuit of a proper magical education
i should mention that
attending a magical school isn't
mandatory in the wizarding world
but opting out certainly isn't
recommended
it's at hogwarts that students are
weaned into and educated on
nearly every aspect of magic that they
should expect to come across in their
lives
failure to attend a wizarding school
just wouldn't be good
however with that being said is hogwarts
entirely accessible
to everyone does everyone get a fair
chance to attend
does it cost money in the magical world
a lot of things can be done and created
with magic
which makes life easier you also might
think that
with the advent of magic things like
money and an economy
are necessary who needs money when you
have magic
right but in reality the wasting world
actually has an economy
very much like our own and is driven by
wizarding currency in the form of
galleons
sickles and canards not unlike our own
world
there exists a medium of exchange which
means that currency is commonly
exchanged for goods
services school books cost money ones
cost money
owls cost money but does hogwarts
rest assured families of the wizarding
world as it turns out that hogwarts
is in fact free this was confirmed by jk
rowling
in a tweet there's no tuition fee the
ministry of magic
covers the cost of all magical education
however
just because the tuition is free it
certainly doesn't mean that the school
is cheap to attend
a first year at hogwarts can expect to
pay for the following a uniform
consisting of three sets of plain black
work robes
one plain black pointed hat one pair of
protective gloves
made of dragon hide or something similar
and one winter cloak
school books including the standard book
of spells grade 1
by miranda goshawk a history of magic by
batilda bagshot
magical theory by adelbert waffling a
beginner's guide to transfiguration by
emmerich switch
one thousand magical herbs in fungi by
philadelphore
magical drafts and potions by arsenius
fantastic beasts and where to
find them by news commander
and the dark forces a guide to
self-protection
by quentin trimble they'll also need a
wand
a cauldron made of pewter a set of glass
files
a telescope a set of brass scales and
lastly
an animal companion commonly an owl cat
or toad
and that's just for first year as you
can see though the hogwarts tuition is
covered by the ministry the school is
far from
free however hogwarts does remain
all-inclusive
and no one will ever be turned away for
students lacking the financial means
you will be delighted to hear that the
school does offer financial aid
and that's it for this video did you
ever wonder if hogwarts costs money
let me know in the comment section below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
you're a wizard harry